russian forces are stepping up their
attacks across ukraine their strikes are
hitting military as well as civilian
targets the assaults come as a new a new
round of talks between ukrainian and
russian negotiators begin
kiev says it wants to discuss a
ceasefire and the immediate withdrawal
of russian troops ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky says citizens have no
choice but to keep up their resistance
despite the heavy loss of life
a russian artillery strike on kiev's
city limits
firefighters rescue people from the
smoldering ruins of a nine-story
apartment building hit during an early
morning attack
part of renewed fighting on the
outskirts of the capital which has so
far resisted russia's advance
president vladimir zelinsky vowed
ultimate victory as he met wounded
soldiers recovering in a keefe military
hospital on a visit to boost morale he
handed out medals in recognition of
their bravery
though russian forces appear to be
widening their attacks across ukraine
zielinski indicated progress could be
made as bilateral talks continue
representatives of our countries are
holding daily talks via video conference
our delegation has a clear task to do
everything to arrange the meeting of the
presidents
the meeting i'm sure people are waiting
for
obviously this is a difficult story
a hard path
but we need this path
on sunday moscow brought its war nearer
to the polish border an attack on a
military training ground near la viv in
western ukraine was the closest strike
so far to nato
territory civilians from all over
ukraine have been fleeing to lev which
felt safe compared to eastern regions
under russian assault
like the city of kramatorsk
eyewitness video from a resident there
showed destruction to her apartment in a
five-story building in the aftermath of
an air raid
[Music]
russia's defense ministry denies
targeting civilians and is holding fast
to its description of its war as a
special military operation
it says its forces have destroyed nearly
4 000 objects of ukraine's military
infrastructure
let's cross over to dw's nick connolly
who's standing by in kiev nick as we saw
there in that report a residential
building within the city limits of kiev
was hit by a russian airstrike what more
can you tell us
well we've seen some pretty shocking
images from the northern
edge of kiev it's about 10 kilometers is
the birds you know direct line from
where i am uh
and
the
building was hit about five in the
morning we're not quite sure yet if it
was an airstrike or if it was artillery
um we have been reading reports in
ukraine media of two people killed and a
further three wounded the
fire began on the kind of ground floor
moved its way up part of the facade
collapsed this is unfortunately no
novelty in kiev now we saw in the first
days of the war a rocket hitting a newly
built apartment block pretty high up
people sent scrambling there
this is now coming close to the center
of kiev where i am now which for now is
still
remarkably
calm and serene even if it is pretty
empty but this is drawing closer by the
day well as the news on kiev is
tightening there are new talks today
between the russian and ukrainian
delegation is there any reason for
ukrainians to be hopeful
i mean that
they need to be hopeful they need to
show that they're willing to turn up for
these talks it's about the optics so
that ukraine is open to dialogue i think
no side neither the russians nor the
ukrainians want to be accused of not
being open to that kind of dialogue but
if you look at the russian demands they
haven't reduced to much yet they're
still basically demanding that ukraine
gives up not only its aspiration to join
nato but also basically gives up a lot
of its military uh and also recognizes
russian possession of annex crimea and
recognizes those self-proclaimed
products in the east so the rhetoric
from russia might be a bit more open to
discussion than it was in the first two
days of this war but if you look at the
nitty gritty they are still demanding a
hell of a lot from ukraine and it'll be
very difficult to see
a situation in which volumizing
ukraine's democratically elected
president could ask his people who have
you know borne extraordinary losses in
recent days to basically give up on all
those
russian demands given to those demands
for ukrainian
basically disarmament and
neutrality in return for what why have
they been fighting for these days it's
going to be a very difficult
negotiation not just with russians but
also with ukraine's people if indeed the
ukrainian government decides to go for
some kind of deal with the russians
now officials in kiev say that preparing
food supplies for the city's remaining
two million inhabitants in case of a
siege
is there any indication how long keefe
would be able to hold out
well obviously this is the scenario that
everyone here has been preparing for for
weeks every kind of couple of days you
get a report that the russians are now
two three days away from in circling
city that hasn't happened so far the
city has held up there are still several
routes in and out city bringing in food
and other supplies but yes that is what
the city government says they are
preparing for at least two weeks worth
of supplies for the estimated two
million people still here in the city um
obviously kiev is the place where
ukraine's military is concentrated that
has the best anti-aircraft uh and
anti-rocket protection just in the last
hour we've heard some pretty loud bangs
and read in the news that those were
russian missiles headed this way that
were intercepted so i think there is no
sense that the ukrainian government is
going to give up its capital without a
fight president zlensky is still here
and it obviously would be a tremendous
blow to ukraine's efforts to defend its
sovereignty if the russians were to take
hold of the capital
well on sunday russia attacked a
military target in the far west of the
country
in striking distance to native nato uh
territory how significant uh is that
i think it's significant for a number of
reasons firstly uh it is pretty close to
the border with nato with poland a place
that has seen hundreds of thousands of
people fleeing the country
in recent days and weeks so even for
people just trying to get out who
thought that they are having left kiev
having left khaki of cities in the
centre in the east of the country they
were in safety they are now very aware
that until they get out of ukraine there
is nowhere that is basically safe but i
think this is also a signal to nato this
was a military base where western
countries carried out training for
ukrainian soldiers how to use those
western weapons they've been using so
successfully against the russians in
recent weeks so this is a part of this
campaign by the kremlin to prevent the
west to discourage the west from
providing ukraine with more
sophisticated weapons we've heard from
vladimir putin recent days he said that
basically as soon as those weapons cross
the ukrainian border they are fair game
and that russia is increasingly seeing
countries who help ukraine militarily as
party to this conflict it's a real
escalation there a sense that russia
would be willing to go after nato
members potentially if they step up that
sport for ukraine
nick connolly there in kiev for us thank
you nick